[Musik]
es ist keineswegs so dass es zu weiteren
strebt jetzt fahrverbote für diese
verhängt hätte sondern im gegenteil das
bundesverwaltungsgericht hat nur
festgestellt dass fahrverbote im
extremfall erlaubt sind es hat sprung
revisionen der länder nordrhein
westfalen und baden württemberg
zugelassen und hat gesagt aber
ausdrücklich dass im extremfall
fahrverbote in betracht zu ziehen sind
um eben die luftreinhaltepläne zu
erfüllen
um also die grenzwerte die ja gesetzlich
vorgegeben sind nicht zu überschreiten
trotzdem bleibt es natürlich in der
freiheit der kommunen die maßnahmen zu
beschließen die dazu beitragen diese
grenzwerte zu erfüllen und letztlich
liegt der spielball damit wieder im
politischen raum fahrverbote sind in
betracht zu ziehen wenn sie die einzige
möglichkeit sind die ganz klasse zu
erreichen aber angeordnet sind sie
dadurch jetzt noch nicht und sie müssen
auch immer unter beachtung des
grundsatzes der verhältnismäßigkeit
durchgezogen werden das heißt hier ist
die rede von handwerkern bestimmten
anwohner gruppen das heißt es geht
immerhin um zeitraum vier jahre nach
einführung der abgasnorm euro 6 also es
war auch genügend zeit die grenzwerte
einzuhalten weil man immer fragen muss
wie denn die gemessen wo wendige messen
das ist ja ein weiterer streitpunkt der
über die man debattieren kann aber es
wird nicht ad hoc für alle fahrverbote
geben das ist auf jeden fall auch eine
botschaft dieser entscheidung des bundes
walter